devant vous les remparts d'une des plus
imposante forteresse de babylone allez
je parle un petit peu en langage reggae
mais c'est la magie qui agit ça veut
dire tout simplement qu'on est dans le
15e arrondissement de paris et que c'est
un grand total américain dans lequel est
descendu à super star du reggae bob
marley pour recevoir deux disques d'or
ni plus ni moins pour ses deux derniers
albums callas rastaman vibration et
c'était une bonne occasion pour parler
avec bob marley du reggae et des débuts
des wales
le début c'était 1963
kingston kingston
noter un petit groupe copytrans un
jour on est tombé sur un professionnel
qui nous aider se plaire jo
c'est lui qui nous a fait répéter nous à
améliorer et c'est grâce à lui qu'on a
pu enregistrer du tout premier dj en
quand est ce que vous avez commencé
c'est pas tellement de succès du succès
m'est
arrivé à faire connaître notre musique
c'était en 73 10 ans après
avec l'album catcheur et puis ensuite
berne est née puis nati du n
b c'est un double album loud
c'est par babylon by basse
pour y expliquer pourquoi ce site
babylone c'est ce système s'il tue les
gens et le rasta c'est celui qui dit que
tu dois vivre l'allégation
qu'est-ce que celles ci ont poussé ces
temps des cerises
mention c'est là où on peut trouver la
paix comme la bonté la communication
avec
ça peut être l'endroit où tu veux à
condition que tu trouves
fsp cette communication avec dieu
c'est ça que ça veut dire
vous êtes en restant what
to be west qu'est ce que ça veut dire
quelles règles de vélines cloud soit de
se battre
être un rasta ça veut dire se mettre
toute sa vie
vous pensez qu'il ya beaucoup de
violence dans la vie quotidienne en
jamaïque à kingston
non je pense que l'aviron cet
international la violence est créée par
des groupes qui fomentent des guerres
pour gagner de l'argent
dans une interview un journal anglais le
melody maker est à peu près un an et
demi j'avais répondu à des critiques qui
vous demander ce que vous feriez devant
la commercialisation du reggae et vous
leur avez répondu on ne ramènera le
mayombe neri qu'est ce que ça veut dire
mais mais mais
il veut dire mort aux oppresseurs noir
et blanc
c'est la musique la plus spirituelle
qui
existe
c'est l'endroit de celui qu'on puisse
atteindre en musique nabeul et n'y sont
pour appeler ça le reggae des racines
c'est pas de reggae c'est le fbi
fait au delà du reggae
mais ce pourrait être la forme la plus
pure de musique jamaïcaine
pur de musique et tout court
[Musique]